the big news today of course the US
takes out Iran's head terrorists Qasem
Soleimani now I certainly don't purport
to be an authority or expert in the
realm of foreign policy but I don't
think you need to be an expert to come
to some very basic conclusions about
things and I base those conclusions on
the facts that are generally agreed upon
by all reasonable people it seems and
those facts are soleimani was an evil
murderous man he was responsible for the
deaths of hundreds of US military
members and and civilians as well he was
he had planned attacks on American soil
in the past including one in DC that was
that was foiled fortunately before it
happened he was behind recent attacks
against Americans and Iraq including the
attack on our embassy a few days ago he
was an ongoing threat to American lives
and the lives of many others many people
of other nationalities including
Iranians by the way now none of that is
disputed from what I've seen the
Pentagon says that Soleimani was also
planning an imminent attack of some kind
against Americans now you could say that
you don't believe that and you know you
don't trust the Pentagon and-and-and but
you don't need to believe it you don't
we don't even need that you don't need
to take the Pentagon's word for it when
it comes to the other points that I just
listed and I think that tells us
everything we need to know in terms of
was this attack morally justified the
thing that finally prompted the u.s. to
respond were the recent attacks
especially at the Embassy
we knew where soleimani was we had his
location Trump ordered the attack took
him out based on all of that
I say it's morally justified now doesn't
make strategic sense from my non expert
perspective it seems to make a lot of
strategic sense yes all of these people
liberals and Democrats mostly we'll talk
about them more in a minute but these
people worrying about escalation or that
this might constitute an act of war and
so on while an attack on our embassy is
an xcode escalation it is an act of war
the only question is whether we will
show a
willingness to respond swiftly and
harshly to that sort of provocation or
not that's the question an unwillingness
to respond you know policy of
appeasement it seems to me like the
policy that Obama had initiated which
included sending pallets of cash to Iran
that kind of policy obviously does not
deescalate or prevent future attacks and
we could clearly see that because if it
did then we wouldn't be having this
conversation right now
Obama appeased for eight years did Iran
deescalate did they back off did they
play nice that it didn't result in peace
and harmony in the Middle East no
obviously not if you don't show a
willingness to protect yourself to
defend yourself to respond in kind
if you don't show that kind of
willingness then you embolden your
enemies and you send the message that
they can do whatever they want and
obviously that's not the message we want
to send look I'm not in favor of regime
change Wars I don't want to be the world
police I've basically been a non
interventionist but taking out a
monstrous scumbag who's been killing
Americans for decades and staged an
attack on our embassy only a few days
ago is neither of those things that's
not being world police and that's not a
regime change war it's appropriate it's
just it's necessary I would argue it's
obviously reckless you know to be
someone who is itching for war all the
time always wanting to intervene always
wanting to send troops over everywhere
and start wars everywhere and there are
people like that and there are fewer
people like that today than there were
say 20 years ago but there are people
out there like that the you know the
so-called neo cons and so forth but the
other extreme end is this anti-war
absolutism that you also find out there
in fact the very notion of being
anti-war is a is really a silly and
unserious position because there are
times when military action is necessary
saying I'm anti-war well in a sense
almost everybody is because nobody likes
or very stupid
anyway like like war but there are
obviously times when you have to respond
that way killing a guy like Soleimani
especially after you after he was behind
the attack on our embassy seems like a
necessary response now here's a question
for us to consider after Trump deployed
hundreds of troops to protect the
embassy in Baghdad and then killed the
guy who coordinated the attack so you've
got the attack on our embassy Trump
sends hundreds of more troops over there
to protect the embassy and then he goes
and kills the guy who coordinated now
basically coming down like a ton of
bricks on everybody associated with it
after that happens do you think our
embassies are more or less likely to be
attacked in the future obviously there's
nothing we can do to make sure that
they're never attacked again anywhere
but is it more or less likely to happen
now because of that do you think future
would-be attackers are more or less
emboldened by this now that they see
what will happen to them that's the
question and there would appear to be an
obvious answer to it if somebody tries
to break into your house and by the way
an embassy that is you know a US Embassy
that's that's American soil that's the
way embassies work if someone tries to
break into your house and you greet them
with a shotgun is that going to
encourage more burglars in the future
are you gonna worry that by doing this
with it you know more more burglars are
going I want to show up maybe maybe for
the challenge they just like a good
challenge no they're not there for the
challenge they have other objectives
they want to steal your TV they want
whatever they want to do people who
attack us attack our people our
embassies they're not doing it for the
challenge they're doing it for other
reasons they have other objectives and
now they know that that calculation
carries a significant amount of risk for
them and it's good that they know that
now they know that if you do that
organist
and we're gonna show up with enforce to
respond and then if you helped
coordinate this thing we're gonna send
drone out to find you and we're gonna
you know turn you into a pot of beef
stew basically I would think that it's
it's good for would-be attackers or
would-be coordinators of attacks to know
that now the next question of course is
what will Iran do in response what
happens next and the first answer to
that obviously is nobody knows exactly
because nobody can look into the future
the second answer is we have to be very
selective about who's guesses and
predictions we trust to notice something
know and I'm not saying to trust my
guess or prediction you shouldn't trust
that but I have noticed that none of the
serious sober minded knowledgeable
voices that I've seen are screaming
about Ward World War three are saying
that World War three is gonna happen now
a lot of people are screaming about
World War three and saying World War
three is gonna happen but none of them
are sober and knowledgeable and that's
probably because Iran is not some
enormous superpower they're basically a
third-rate power and they would get
annihilated in a direct all-out war with
the United States which doesn't mean
that they issue no response at all
obviously they could respond on a
smaller scale they could respond through
proxies they could attack our interests
and our people directly and exactly how
all of that will shake out I don't know
but I do know that all all of the things
they could do in response they've
already done and are already doing and
would have continued continued to do if
they were unopposed we just have to
continue to be swift decisive and smart
in response to whatever they do in the
future that's basically my take on this
but Democrats have a different tank
unsurprisingly and their take is that
well there are take is basically that
protecting our embassies and killing
terrorists who kill Americans is bad if
Trump does it not a surprising take
that's their take on everything did
Trump do it it's bad very very very
simple calculation they have to make
almost an almost there's an enviable
simplicity to it it would be nice to
live in a world like that we don't have
to think too much about things all you
have to say is did Trump do it this
Trump supported well I'm against it now
they haven't put it quite like that most
of the time but that's the gist and
we'll run down some of the lowlights of
the Democratic response to this in a
minute but first you know I like to do
my research on my sponsors on the show
and I only recommend brands to my
listeners that I believe in and I can
say with full confidence that expressvpn
is the best VPN on the market here's why
expressvpn doesn't just log your data
they've you know lots of really cheap
and free VPNs make money by selling your
data to ad companies that's not what
Xpress VPN is all about expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server that it makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
okay so they're not going to do that if
you want to go if you want to go the the
the cheap easy route and find some find
some you know some other VPN well then
that's what's gonna happen we don't
worry about that with expressvpn the
second thing is speed no I've tried lots
of VPNs in the past many of them slow
your connection speed down and make your
devices very sluggish that's that's a
problem for me especially because I live
my entire life on the Internet
unfortunately so I've been using Express
VPN for months and my internet speeds
are blazing fast even when I connect to
servers thousands of miles away I can
still stream HD quality videos with zero
lag the last thing that really sets
Xpress expressvpn apart from other VPNs
is how easy it is to use unlike other
VPNs you don't have to input or program
anything which is also good for me
because I really don't know even though
I'm on computers all the time and all
the internet all the time I'm also
basically illiterate with it I don't
know what I'm doing with computers
so they make it very easy so you know
you have that security you
no you have the convenience of it you
know you have speed it's easy to use so
to protect yourself with the VPN that I
use and I trust use my link expressvpn
comm slash Walsh today get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's expressvpn express letters VPN
dot-com slash Walsh visit expressvpn
comm slash Walsh to learn more well they
haven't all been quite this bad but
because this is about as bad as it gets
but Rose McGowan she's the former
Hollywood actress I don't know what she
does for a living now but she sent out a
tweet last night saying dear Iran the
USA has disrespected your country your
flag your people 52% of us humbly
apologize we want peace with your nation
we are being held hostage by a terrorist
regime regime we do not know how to
escape please do not kill us
hashtag Soleimani I mean what do you
even say to that cowering to a terrorist
regime begging for mercy apologizing
Democrats might elect her president if
she keeps this up although there is one
point here aside from the question of
where did she get the 52 percent figure
from 52 percent of us apologize did she
pull everybody before she sent this
tweet out but I think the the bigger
point here is you know Rose maybe I can
help you out she says that she doesn't
know how to escape well it's pretty easy
Rose you have a passport right okay so
you I assume you have a passport well go
to the airport get on a plane and that's
it the plane will do most of the rest of
the work and you'll just you can go
anywhere you want you can leave the
country and I'm not one to always resort
to thee if you don't like America get
out thing but if this is your position
that you're that there's a terrorist
regime and power you're being held
against your will you know then you just
if I felt that way I would leave
so you are free to do that in fact you
could go to Iran if you want deliver
your love letter in person see if you
like how you're treated over there
meanwhile a reporter for The New York
Times and and I'm not making this up
a reporter for the New York Times hours
after the strike posted well just showed
you well posted this video watch yo
namond isuzu Joe Montana has Authority
phenomenal here's the caption that went
with that video
rare personal video of general Soleimani
reciting poetry chaired by a source and
iran about friends departing and him
being left behind totally normal right
you're posting this sympathetic video of
the terrorists reciting poetry this is
like right after bin laden was killed
here's a silly video of Osama singing
take on me at Taliban karaoke night
meanwhile a CNN reporter Sam vino grad
tweeted Soleimani was a terrorist who
was responsible for four horrific
actions Iran will consider this an act
of war President Trump doesn't rely on
intelligence for anything so it is
unlikely that he fully understands the
repercussion repercussions of this
action Iran will consider this an act of
war they attacked our embassy that was
an act of war the act of war already
happened
what kind of gutless and nonsense is a
country makes an act of war against the
United States and you say we shouldn't
respond to the act of war because it
would be an act of war oh no we can't
respond to an act of war with an act of
war because that might cause them to do
an act of war I mean another act of war
on top of all the other acts of war
they'd already done but you know we
can't that and it gets worse the daily
wire has an article up right now
compiling the Democratic reaction to the
sulemani strike let me read some of this
on The Daily wire calm
says socialist Democrat presidential
candidate Bernie Sanders responded by
tweeting Trump's dangerous escalation
brings us closer to another disastrous
war in Middle East that would cost
millions of cost countless lives and
trillions more dollars Trump promised to
end the endless wars but this action
puts us on the path to another one
Democrat presidential candidate
Elizabeth Warren responded by writing on
Twitter soleimani was a murderer
responsible for thousands of deaths
including hundreds of Americans but this
reckless move escalates the situation
with Iran and increases the likelihood
of more deaths and new Middle East
conflict our priority must be to avoid
another costly war let's just before I
continue let's review what they're
calling a reckless
you know thoughtless move it was killing
the guy who Elizabeth Warren herself
describes as a mass murderer who was in
Iraq after having just helped coordinate
a tackle an American embassy killing
that guy was reckless okay Democrat
presidential candidate marianne
williamson responded by writing prayers
for peace killing of Qasem Soleimani was
by milla US military was one of the most
reckless irresponsible direct actions
ever directed by a US president Congress
deserves condemnation for allowing it
and Americans need to understand this
war with Iran would be totally
disastrous well Mary Ann maybe you could
grab your peace crystal and get to work
I mean really I blame you you're the one
that's supposed to be harnessing all of
the goodwill and all of the positive
energy in the universe through your
crystals where if your crystals been
what did you leave them up in the attic
get the crystals out get to work the
whole world's gonna come to an end
because of you Mary Ann far-left
political commentator crystal ball
tweeted speaking of crystals no one
voted for this no one authorized it yet
here we are in the precipice of war with
Iran if we assassinated Soleimani it's
hard to overstate just what a massive
escalation and dangerous situation is
president just put us in Democrat
President presidential candidate Andrew
Andrew yang responded war with
Rann is the last thing we need and is
not the will of the American people we
should be acting to deescalate tensions
and protect our people in the region far
laughs young turks writer emma violin
tweeted imagine the Iranian government
assassinating Mike Pompeo with a drone
at the direction of the President and
called it self-defense that's exactly
what the US did by killing solo Manning
an act of war Democrat Senator Chris
Murphy said just a few days ago that
Trump has rendered America impotent in
the Middle East no one fears us no one
listens to us but then Murphy responded
to news that Trump killed Soleimani by
writing Soleimani was an enemy the
United States that's not a question the
question is this as reports suggest that
America just assassinated without any
congressional authority the second most
powerful person in Iran knowingly
setting off a potential massive regional
war and on and on and on so you get the
you of the gist of it
you've got the media you've got Democrat
presidential candidates they're all
opposed to it they all are worried about
war with Iran look okay a few a few
things here first of all calling this an
assassination is just trade up Iranian
propaganda you may as well be working
for the Iranian government sulla mani
was a terrorist
operating illegally he was an aggressor
against the United States he was killed
in a war zone
this was not an assassination
assassination is what they will call it
comparing it to killing a US official
like Mike Pompeo that's that is again
Iranian propaganda that's what that's
how they're going to phrase it that's
how they're gonna put it and frame it
second you know there there are many
reasonable things that you could say or
you know a reasonable person could
speculate or or worry about where this
is gonna head what's gonna happen next I
think we would be fools if we weren't
you know somewhat worried because we're
in you know weed weed weed it's it's
it is it's a contentious situation to
put it mildly
so there's nothing wrong with that and
I've seen plenty of reasonable people
who've said listen I think this was a
right the right thing to do I think it
was necessary but this could go any
number of directions and so you know
here are some directions it could go
that wouldn't be so good that that's
fine but to act as though Iran is some
massive superpower and we've just poked
the bear and now they're gonna rise up
and destroy us which is the way some of
the Democrats are essentially
positioning this is absurd I mean it's
unamerican it's ridiculous it's
sensationalist it's fear-mongering a
third thing is there any doubt that
every Democrat in the country will be
tripping over themselves to extol the
brilliance of this move if Obama had
done it is there any doubt now there are
on the on the fringes of the left there
is a there are some people a few people
who are consistent on these things and
in fact did hold Obama accountable
during his administration for doing
things like assassinating American
citizens via drone strike which is
something that Obama did do but those
voices are few and far between for the
most part when Obama was in office
whatever he did drone strikes whatever
Democrats were totally behind it so is
there any doubt at all if this was if
this was Obama who did that is there any
doubt that most of these Democrats would
be saying that it was a brilliant move
it was morally right it was
strategically wise on and on and on and
so on and so forth no we have no doubt
about that
because these people have no integrity
whatsoever you could claim that the same
is true on the other end and if Obama
had done this most Republicans will be
criticizing it but
it's actually not true and I'm not
saying that Republicans are above being
tribalistic they obviously aren't but on
issues like this Democrats are far more
tribalistic when it comes to in my view
when it comes to foreign policy
especially Democrats are far more
tribalistic and are far more likely to
completely change their foreign policy
principles depending on if it's a guy
with a D or an R next to his name in the
White House I think that you know 99% of
the Republicans who are celebrating this
or at least supporting it now would be
doing the same if it was Obama in office
but that's how Democrats operate all
right let's move on to some other big
news that I don't want to be I don't
want to get completely overshadowed
reading again from The Daily wire says
congressional Republicans have now taken
aim at the infamous decision roe v wade
by urging the Supreme Court to revisit
the nearly 50-year old case that
enshrined abortion as a constitutional
right across all 50 states 39 Republican
senators and 168 members of the House of
Representatives almost all of the
Republicans signed a so-called friend of
the court brief filed on Thursday by the
National anti-abortion group Americans
United for life in connection with a
challenge to lose the Louisiana abortion
access law due to be heard in March the
Louisiana case before the court does not
directly target Roe the report continued
the law issue requires a doctor to have
admitting privileges at a hospital
within 30 miles of the facility where
the abortion is performed which critics
say is not medically justified according
to the brief Roe's jurisprudence has
been haphazard from the beginning due to
becoming a radically unsettled precedent
that quote has been substantially
undermined by subsequent of Authority
arguing that previous court rulings
quote clearly did not settle the
abortion issue the brief urges SCOTUS to
reconsider those precedents and then it
goes on from there it's interesting a
report on The Daily wire you can go and
read and of course that raises the
question are we going to get any kind of
direct confrontation with
or challenge to roe v-- wade with the
way the court is currently constituted I
wouldn't it all be confident that roe v
wade would get overturned and that's
part of the irony actually about the way
the just how fervent the left was
obviously in trying to stop somebody
like Cavanaugh from getting on the court
and saying that Cavanaugh is going to
attack abortion in Roe V white roe v
wade and all this
I don't think Cavanaugh would vote to
overturn roe v wade I could be wrong I
really don't think he would but when it
comes to roe v wade you know if if you
have if you have any integrity again and
it doesn't even matter how you feel
about abortion personally even if you're
in favor of abortion if you're in favor
of abortion but you have integrity and
maybe there's a paradox there maybe
there's a just that's impossible how
could a person with integrity be in
favor of abortion probably they can't
and I think that's the problem but if
there was anyone in that category that
exists then they would have to admit
that roe v wade putting abortion to the
side how you personally feel about roe v
wade is a disastrous legal opinion on
just a legal level it's a it was a
disastrous decision by the supreme court
because what they did was they located a
fictional right to abortion in the right
to privacy provision which also doesn't
exist and if it did exist it would have
nothing to do with abortion so based on
a rights of privacy which has nothing to
do with abortion and also doesn't exist
in the Constitution they found they
located a right to abortion and it's
just that of course makes no sense on a
legal level and on that basis alone roe
v wade should be should be overturned
let's move on to emails Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
there was one here that was interesting
I wanted to spend some time okay if this
is from Brandon says Matt I was confused
by some of your tweets last night
talking about the Iran situation someone
said that the US response isn't biblical
and you seem to suggest that Jesus's
words in the Bible don't apply to
governments but only to individuals are
you saying the government can do
whatever it wants morally according to
the Bible well Brandon of course I'm not
saying that just backing up for a moment
here a few people challenged me last
night basically taking the position that
Jesus was anti-war and the Bible is
anti-war and you know all the stuff
about don't take vengeance turn the
other cheek and so on should disqualify
us from doing things like killing
terrorists and we've we've all heard
this before we've we've all encountered
this version of Jesus as this peacenik
anti-war hippie right somebody quoted
Paul in Romans saying that either the
verse in Romans talking about beloved
don't take vengeance leave it to God I'm
paraphrasing now here's my point and
Romans is actually a great example so
it's good that the person quoted it even
though the person who quoted it
obviously had never read the entire
letter because if you read the entire
letter of Romans you would see that in
the very same letter Paul in his only
explicit mention of the states in that
letter specifically affirms the state's
authority to wield the sword and take
lives so you know at one point he's
saying beloved don't take vengeance yet
at another point he says that the state
can wield the sword and take lives in
the name of justice how do we make sense
of that well because it's simply the
case that many of the moral edicts and
commands given in the Bible are given to
individuals not to governments as a
whole that doesn't mean that governments
can do whatever they want intrinsically
immoral
are intrinsically immoral no matter who
does them so rape is intrinsically
immoral which means that individual
people can't do it and the government
can't you know come up with some policy
where they you know subject prisoners of
war to rape or whatever slavery is
intrinsically immoral
lots of things are intrinsically more
killing is not intrinsically and more
killing is a matter of authority so what
the Bible tells us is that we as
individuals do not have the authority to
go out and kill in the name of justice
we can kill in self-defense obviously
and or in the defense of those we love
but we are not empowered to go out and
be vigilantes to be like superheroes we
can't go out on the street looking for
bad guys to bring to justice
we are not empowered to do that the
government is empowered to do that does
it abuse that power well of course it
does but the Bible does grant that power
to the state not just in Romans but
throughout the text old and new
Testament and so that's my point and
that's why you can't just haphazardly
take a verse here and a verse there and
apply it to foreign policy which again
doesn't mean that our foreign policy is
totally exempt from everything that's in
the Bible but it does mean that you
can't do it that way and when Jesus says
turn the other cheek so he's talking to
you individually as a person and me and
he's saying that if you are insulted
personally then the correct response is
to turn the other cheek you cannot take
that and extrapolate it into a and
pretend that Jesus was giving advice on
foreign policy and on how
nations are supposed to respond to
things like terrorism now you're taking
turn the other cheek which is a very
simple but important command and you're
turning it you're you're expanding it
into oblivion and you're turning it into
something incoherent what now we're
gonna pretend that Jesus is saying that
that if if a nation is attacked by
another nation the nation shouldn't
defend itself no the government has a
responsibility to defend its citizens
and if we're attacked or if we're under
threat the government has a
responsibility to respond no we don't we
don't want the government to turn the
other cheek to aggressors and terrorists
and you know a enemy powers so you just
got to be a you know we've we've I say
again and again you've got to look at
the context in the Bible you can't take
anything just in isolation and pluck a
sentence out of its context you can't do
that do that you have to look at the
context and you have to have this is
very important look at who these
comments or commands are being directed
at let's see this is from Antonio says
hi Matt I'm sorry the Pope is ignoring
you if he followed your podcast he would
surely be a better Pope well that's I'd
have to agree with you there I'm only
writing to advise you to watch the best
movie in recent years the peanut butter
Falcon I'd like to hear your comment on
this movie good start of the decade with
devotion Antonio
yeah I actually did watch the peanut
butter Falcon that's the Shia LeBouf
LaBeouf movie i watch with my wife a few
few weeks ago and I thought it was it
was a delightful movie basically
family-friendly I mean I've got six year
old kids probably would watch it with
them but you know if you've got older
kids it's a family-friendly kind of very
Mark Twain Ian sort of just adventure
slash coming-of-age tale and I really I
really enjoy
I'm not a big fan of Shia LaBeouf but he
he impressed me in that one so I will I
will also give my stamp of approval on
the peanut butter Falcon a little bit of
a little bit of a weird ending but other
than that pretty good movie this is from
Larry says hi Matt I saw you talking
about fishing the other day didn't
realize you were an angler here's a good
question for you from someone who's just
getting into it what is the biggest
mistake novice bass fisherman make well
there's a lot of mistakes I mean pretty
much everything I know when I when I
first started fishing I'd say I did
everything wrong and there there are
many things you could point to one of
them is is you know not choosing the
right color of lure depending on the
water clarity and the season and the
color of the bait that's actually in the
lake or the body of water you're fishing
on you have to be sure that if you have
to know what else is in the lake and try
to match your your the color of your
bait to that and then again like I said
water clarity is important so if it's if
it's a crystal-clear lake then you want
your colors to be very muted and and and
realistic if it's a mercury Lake then
you want to go I they're really really
dark so you get that nice silhouette the
fish can see or may be really bright you
know this is where you want to get
louder and more obnoxious just just so
the fish can can locate the bait so
that's a mistake people make mistakes in
presentation you know it's important in
a Clear Lake the way that you make the
bait move under the water that's gonna
trigger or not trigger the reaction bite
from the fish fish or predators bass
fish or predators and so you want to
trigger that instinct to go after the
debate that's that's gonna be a lot of
that is gonna be presentation but I
would say the the number one mistake at
least the number one mistake I made was
location not finding the right location
and staying and and being - staying put
rather than you know not being mobile
enough because when you're fishing this
is really hunting and you're going out
and you got to find where the fish are
yeah it's it seems like a really basic
and obvious tip and it is but it's one
that took me a while to figure out okay
yeah if you're fishing actually have to
find where the fish are first which
means that you
a lake or something I see people doing
this all the time I see guys at legs and
they you know they just walk out onto a
dock or they're on the the bank and they
just are standing there for hours just
casting out in the same spot just
obviously there's no fish there so you
want to look at location if it's in the
summer especially you know you want to
look in shady spots you're looking
around structure okay if there's rocks
and stumps and things you want to go to
grass you want to go to weeds all that
stuff that's where fish are gonna hide
out they're not just gonna be out in the
middle of you know some if there's some
big open spot in the middle lake they're
probably not gonna be there if it's
colder if you're trying to go fishing
right now for example then you want to
go deep which unless you know the
topography of the lake unless you know
what's under there it's it's probably a
waste of time so you want to know like
if you can go deep and you happen to
know if you're in 20 feet of water and
you happen to know that underneath you
there's grass or there's structure
there's an underwater island or
something then then that could be a good
spot if you have no idea what's under
the lake and it's a big lake probably
just going on into the middle lake and
throwing a bait in is you know you're
probably not gonna catch anything but
you know doesn't mean you can't try so
that would be the main thing you want to
keep you want to you want to find the
right location you want to keep moving
if you're in a location and there's no
fish there then you want to move to the
next spot this is what makes fishing off
of the shore more difficult than if
you're in a boat because you're a little
bit less mobile but just keep moving and
you know they say that ninety percent of
the fish will be in ten percent of the
lake so keep that in mind you got to
find that ten percent and if you're in a
spot you're not getting any bites could
be that you're in the you know the
ninety percent where there aren't any
fish alright thanks for that for that
question though I I did threaten on
Twitter a few days ago to do an entire
show on bass fishing tips and don't put
it past me to do that if I keep getting
emails like this you know you might
tempt me
but thanks for that and hope everyone
has a great weekend nice short week for
us Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there